today we are going to be talking about
unlocking value from data analytics from
a practical point of view I'm gonna be
sharing things I've been learning from
my experience
and
this talk is for you if you are working
in a data team or will benefit to having
better data and analytics and also if
you are a stakeholder decision making
and how to manage in data within your
organization
uh so
a bit of introduction
uh I'm a data engineering consultant I
started my own company recently called
Data Feria and I'm director as well of
Eastern Canada
Consulting in UK where we specialize
in full stack data engineering
and I've been
formerly Amazon lead data engineer so
working in a material learning product
globally
um I have 15 years of experience uh
including a number of sectors like a
property market energy Pharmacy Telecom
on the public sector and finance
institutions to name one a few
and my background is in biology and I
have three Masters Degree where I
specialize in technology and soon in my
career I started working with data data
processing
so
data is quite vast but we just utilize a
very fraction of it it's calculated
about only five percent of all the data
that could be used uh is actually
utilized by companies
um on the other hand we have
a very really complex ecosystem of Tools
around data is really a skyrocketing the
number of tools that you can use
nowadays to perform data engineering a
tasks or data analytics and machine
learning products
and this is adding complexity into the
mix
and
this complexity is sitting within the
the heart of all the the data uh flow
and access of information within an
organization that impact every single
unit within a company so data
engineering produced all the data
manipulation so from ingestion to data
processing to prepare it in a way for
consumers to produce analytics or
machine learning products that are going
to be impacting
all the the business from cells to to
Legal finance and operations
So within this complexity and
busting task of producing all this
information for all the stakeholders I
was not surprised to hear about this
Statistics
so
according to a recent research
97 of data Engineers reported to be to
feel burned out so that's quite a high
number so obviously this is also
impacting on the job
satisfaction or lack of job satisfaction
and the retention rate within this field
usually is low
so
Within
this scenario we have
a typical
company so company a is your typical
company where
data is very fragmented usually living
in silos across different units in the
organization
there's problems because it's not
Consolidated and it's not accessible for
people to to uh to query and make
informed decisions
so in this type of organization business
a it's also a small number of people
within the organization that has access
to that data uh usually less than one
percent know how has access and know how
to query the information
so
data access requires in these
organizations that have data experts so
either data Engineers or analysts bi
people or even data scientists often are
facilitating information
obtaining ad hoc's requests
so what's happening in these
organizations that is your typical
organization is the decision making
is most of the time based on guesswork
um in experiences based on the
experience of the the people working on
the organization and intuition
um so we have on the other side business
b a business B
have data in a Consolidated way
um is is how securely and is accessible
for people to action on that information
so in this organization most people
are data literate so meaning they know
how to uh query information they know
how to use the tools that are available
for them uh to create infographic create
report
numbers that can validate hypothesis
they they have
so the data here in this organization is
self-service so about 80 percent of the
data
that is required for someone to to
perform his his job is is available and
they they have the capacity to or to
request and self-serve these this
information
and because of these these organizations
are able to
make decisions based on facts and they
use also intuition and experience but
they can prove hypothesis and make a
case to create a bigger budget for a
particular product or whatever business
decision they can use data and numbers
to uh
to validate this hypothesis
so
within this these two companies uh I'm
sure that most of us we will liked and
we would love to work for Company B and
unfortunately most of companies are in a
stage of business business a so
how we go for
um
creating more companies be where we we
have more uh access to to data in a in a
way that business decisions can be
driven by information so how can we
convert these problems into
opportunities
so
a thing that we need to start on the
process of building a data product
anytime you build a product uh that
happens that there are three elements
that you need to balance so you have
certain amount of time and energy
and resources that you can put into
building a product and usually you have
to make decisions what to what to make a
product either and work on making really
fit to Market so
build whatever the customer wants versus
building the product fast
or building a product in the right way
so these three elements uh interact with
each other and require different
uh efforts and often compete with the
resources that are available
it happens quite often that when we
launch a product obviously we wanted to
be the right product for our customer
and be the the right
the right thing to build and that's why
the the fit to Market Market fit is the
first thing that we we really care about
it and there is a reason why we it
doesn't make sense we are building data
product that doesn't have the impact we
are looking for so
and when you create
um first product absolutely a market fit
is super important as well as building
the product as fast as as fast as
possible as quickly as possible
um to validate your hypothesis
now it's often happens at the third so
building the product in the right way is
Left Behind so it's left behind at the
beginning for a reason but my point I
want to make here is that soon after you
have validated your product
um are able to
create a production pipeline for that
soon enough you want to put your effort
in building it in the the right way so
there is a lot of literature about how
to make a cicd pipeline in the right
way and creating monitoring creating the
data quality checks and all the good
development practices within a data
product you absolutely want to build
these as soon as possible
um
so it happens that
this uh building the right way is gonna
impact very soon your capacity to build
new features and maintain your product
relevant
uh so this affects uh as well the the
quality of how your product is fitting
uh that customer needs
and building in the right way is also
ultimately affecting the market fit
um because you are going to be able to
build a trust within your product uh
when you have a robust in architecture
and data Pipeline and all the
measurements that is impacting this
information at this this particular
product so it's at the end of the day
it's a flywheel that interact with each
other so what at the beginning we are
putting the focus on the market fit and
building quickly enough we soon need to
put the focus on building our data
infrastructure in the the right way
so
these
processes how you make sure that your
balancing these three elements
um in the right way how would you make
sure that you're putting the right
effort in these three departments so
my point is you need to mature you need
to have metrics that is validating these
different dimensions but in particular
within data engineering that is often a
black box for businesses often happens
that the different divisions they don't
know really much what is going on within
data engineered they believe there is
some kind of smart people working there
and they don't understand pretty much
what is going on even
stakeholders within data teams that have
senior positions often are you know well
connected with what is going on in the
granular level
within data engineering team is just
um
complexity and it's also complex for
people outside that seem to understand
what is going on there so because of
that is fundamental it's crucial to have
the right to have metrics that validate
that you have uh engineering function
that is a fit for purpose and it's
healthy and is is
creating value within the business and
supporting all the other units within a
business
so
obviously we have heard all about what
you cannot improve uh what you cannot do
you are not measuring so
on the data engineering side I think is
important to be maturing things like the
data model consistency
um so as we have been building products
within data engineering especially from
the 2000 when we have this boom of a
microservices and cloud services and we
have moved from relational databases
with three normalization rules to a more
fragmented ecosystem where we have
unstructured data and data legs and
machine learning and streaming and all
these different data sources uh having
consistency across data models is
um is a must and you you need to put
effort consciously to guarantee that
data consistency across platforms
um foreign
matures uh metrics that give people in
the business and not only data engineer
but outside the team of data Engineers
to have this ability of how is the
health within the data model consistency
across the the business is quite crucial
the same as goes for data privacy and
security uh it's really really important
especially nowadays we we have a
regulation like a gdpr
um and we have news about data breaks
and cyber security is so important and
it's really crucial you are measuring
data privacy and security within your
data engineering's units
is it's often
um
overlooked and
um is not it's not that difficult with
the tool we have nowadays to gain
visibility on on this this front
the other block of measures you want to
have is around data accessibility so is
my data available
across the different business units that
need to have access so who has access to
what and have measures of this is is
really relevant and the other block is
about data pipeline health
and
while your data team might have a long
list of
metrics to diagnose and monitor the data
pipeline is also important to have a
number of those high level that are
assets by the the rest of the business
and the other block is about technical
debt so are we measuring uh how fast we
are building a product pursues improving
our
repositories our code and our
infrastructure
and our data security data quality
checks
um I would how much time are we spending
on troubleshooting and in technical
update or Legacy system we are
maintaining versus building things and
improving our systems
so and this
um this block is
um I think are the most important or the
different
um sections I would be considering for
measuring and making sense of data
engineering and
transforming that black box that you
often data engineering is to something
the business can action and understand
and
finally I want to talk about data
culture so in order to become that
business B data-driven business
it is
a a work that underpin every single unit
within a business
is is not on by the data team is not
owned by data engineering this requires
a business culture shift and a lot of
effort to make
this reality within the business
so
you you want to have a culture where you
Empower people and
and people have the education to either
have been able to write minimal SQL
queries to retrieve information
uh or have knowledge about using certain
tools that allow them
to query the information and create
graph in different ways
but
um
having having this as a culture so
you're providing the resources the
education the training required
and help people to utilize that
information coverage people to use the
information to make decisions is
fundamental
so the best businesses I work for they
actually really have most of people in
the business sells a marketing Finance
they are able to to query the
information is relevant for them to the
Canon brand it be tasting they can have
validated processes they can create uh
product roadmaps using relevant
information
so building a data culture is a big task
and it requires really putting the
effort there to unblock your data team
so become more visible and you
understand what is going on there uh do
you really connect this unique with the
rest of the business and you put the
effort in building the uh the data the
team and the people working around
the information so that's involved the
education in terms of data access cell
service uh functional skills so how you
plot graph the data how you think
critically about the information
so they teach us a model of the reality
and we need to understand also the flows
of the information we we are utilizing
um how what is the confidence intervals
of that piece of data
um how consistent coherence is
um understanding and thinking critically
also is is really truly important and of
course data privacy and security is
Paramount so having people understanding
when data is confidential or not and how
what to do with
um
the information that is dubious and
they might have
a concern about it or information that
they take that might be inflicting some
bi or rules around gdpr so this is a
work that involve every single person in
your organization
so
without
without more due since
um
this is the end of the of my talk thank
you very much for uh for watching
um and I and I which is uh it was useful
and open for any any questions I will
follow up in the in the chat
and
yeah without more due let me see if I
can see questions coming
so
if there is no any questions I will
follow up in the
within the Discord so I will be
available
um you have any questions and thank you
thank you very much for uh